you know what i was watching last night
my girl's obsessed with it but i ruined
it for because i looked up the results
have you seen uh married at first sight
hey oh yeah
just started watching it it's season
nines on netflix we just started
watching
it's great i was like this [ __ ] is so
stupid because they have these experts
they're putting together these people
who've never figured out relationship
they marry him right away
it's awkward as [ __ ] my girl's like
they're i think all four are going to
make them like i guarantee you they
don't she's i think all four i went
you what do you want to bet i guarantee
you that right now in this honeymoon
phase
there's cameras there's some to [ __ ]
tahiti on
like this it's like bachelor like that
[ __ ] ain't real because once that show
ends
you're in the two-bedroom apartment in
burbank and there's no [ __ ] cameras
around
and you're stuck with this dude that you
don't know would know shoes like i
guarantee it's gonna make it so i'm like
this is over watch this i looked it up
spoiler in three
no two one one of them [ __ ] make it
the the the the black couple were real
like who i didn't like at first but then
they grew on me they
grew up yeah they were my favorite
couple because they were they were so
real about it because
like they just got married and she was
she's been single for 10 years
he's not like a ladies man he's a little
bit of a nerd and they're they just
eased into it like you should in a
relationship and they like they weren't
like holding hands at first anything
and now you know they have a kid no oh
[ __ ] is that [ __ ] ain't no nerd yep
but then you know the big tall
basketball player yeah with a small tiny
little girl
yeah dude how about never brush his
teeth didn't have a toothbrush the
entire time
i had two girlfriends while he was
married wait wait yeah he was always
like
gone tell him
i was over the show once i found the
results so i just kept looking deeper
and deeper
and the girl was like yeah we broke up
she goes the bummer thing is is like the
show was still
filming and i had to kiss him and he'd
never brush his teeth ew
wait the black guy or no no this guy oh
my god i was about about to say
that man with that good haircut can
brush his teeth he didn't give a [ __ ]
the couple in the middle made it the
couple on the right the girl's pretty
right on the far right
virgin and the dude on the on the left
her husband big dick
well known big dick because when they
they go through it they go through your
house and you have the
the magnum double x's and the girls like
damn and you shut them
up
i don't know if you need all of that but
anyway
after that big sean i had other my girl
i bought two of the packs so
they go to his house we know the man has
a big dick so then
uh she's a virgin she's been a virgin
for 27 years
dude they go on honeymoon nothing and
finally they broke up she's like dude
i'm talking
nothing like she do you think she wants
to start off with that
that is start off with yeah this dick
ain't going to suck itself
and we're she's been a virgin for 27
years
she sees that release the cracking
release the crack
right you're married dog yo put up put
put up people what you mean when he saw
that big giant
you would think she'd want to jump his
bones yeah 27 years
but check this out so when they get
married they're on the honeymoon the
first night they're in this like ocean
side whatever
and my girl's like which ones you do you
think you're gonna hook up i called it
[ __ ] spot on
i was like that [ __ ] is gonna have sex
first night that little girl's gonna
have sex first night the other two
aren't gonna do [ __ ]
the black enough i was right who looked
who so who got the two black girls
that girl in the middle super
promiscuous like the way the dick taste
she had she they got it on the far right
the little girl who i like
they got it on she's crazy though she's
like the one on far right yeah the time
she's cool though i like that she's cool
but she's like
like living in in a dream world she's
like she thinks like that's the perfect
man for her but he continues to like
mess up on her yeah
she's well they're not together she
cries together anymore
but then uh yeah so none of those
couples made it so the ones on the far
left
because they're the most real they were
so real with each other oh well shouts
out to them
yeah they're we'll send them two
t-shirts
me and my girlfriend both are like oh
there's something weird about them but
then we love them afterwards
like they're they're our favorite couple
afterwards do you guys have what you
should watch with your girlfriend i know
you hate shows i'm just like you with
shows like especially
you know these like game shows yeah i
always go to
wikipedia and i just started looking
through that's like because that's when
my girl started arguing like oh yeah
yeah
i always look through the [ __ ] i do that
with big brother i still watch it you
know but i'm like i got it i see i'm
over it i'm around like episode eight
i'm like yeah i know the results
yeah i don't care about spoilers i'm
like yeah spoiler go ahead time
yeah it's really should watch also on
netflix is tara's house
i talked about this before it's japanese
it's a japanese one you have to read
which sucks
subtitles but it's really really good
what's it about it's just like
all these shows like yeah so they move
into a house and they're supposed to
like find who they want to be with
okay in that house and it's filmed so
really what like
amazingly well it's well shot yeah well
shot and one of the girls
that's not really a spoiler because it
happened in real life she ended up
killing herself
ooh i mean because of comments because
some comments yeah
text me the name of the show she gotta
understand you gotta have thick skin for
these comments
hey he replies to him i'm replying to me
in comments oh stay on dude
now you're on this you gotta stay off
all right all right all right because
it'll start changing the way you
approach the show oh yeah stop being
yourself you know okay
yeah yeah i would just want to be
yourself
i get mad when they try to come for you
in the comments that's what it hit me
they when they come out to bring it it
hit me like home i was like you don't
even know what the [ __ ] you talking
about
but you getting ready becky how the hell
he been making this show
wow how can he make it better you tell
me
huh he got two black eyes what because
of this generation tell us how to make
it better
you can't see the z i can't come on
becky
let me know wait shoot should you say
that i have two black guys
yeah it's because of the generation
that's like oh it's generally because
they're like
the climate she was like oh of course
she's gonna like replace with two black
guys
he's been [ __ ] with ethnicity for me
thank you thank you
thank you yeah does does that dumb [ __ ]
know that you guys come on the road with
me how long have i been [ __ ] with
chappelle
for long before this show before i even
moved to california
but even before that my mcn headliner
one was an
indian dude and the other was a black
guy she was like you know
that [ __ ] pissed me off when they don't
know what they talking about though but
that's why i can't read them
you know because they're full of no i
don't have any like they don't
and now you got a girl with six figures
six figures six feet look what he did
i'm going to hard throwing and passing
out tacos
now you're moving yeah come on now
you're moving out what's up
come on bro i just i get mad i just
gotta what are we doing here you know
i'm ignorant
i'm gonna watch your show but have you
watched uh love on the spectrum
no what
yeah everyone looks slightly off in that
photo let me just show you the picture
real quick because it was
freaking funny whose account was on
little brows maybe
no wait wait who is who is that do we
know you guys
oh boy oh yeah he's our boy pop star oh
he's also the manager of uh
korean zombie cat posted it okay cat
posted it
damn what you looking for my nicotine
job
damn calm down homie i think i think
it's all right
what the hell is wrong with you she was
like she
someone said uh little brows looks like
simple jab
oh
yeah what they say i look like huh
people just lighten them it's just funny
our faces do look like we're on the
shelf
mr
love on the spectrum you've been
watching this i finished this in like
two days oh [ __ ] you know that black
cook from uh south park
uh chef oh is that his name yeah
what about him nothing anyways uh
uh the show is fantastic so uh it's
refreshing because
since they have autism they're like so
up front so
no honesty they don't hold back at all
so uh the girl goes so you know they're
obviously socially awkward but
mentally they're beasts man like a lot
of them are beast with numbers or
whatever it is like rain man
so uh this one dude's on a date with a
girl and
she's like so do you go on a lot of
dates he's like yeah but i usually date
asian girls
and she's like oh i'm not asian cuz i
know that's why this isn't gonna work
out
damn and then it should but like there's
no [ __ ] he said you know most
normal people like oh well you know i'm
open this dude's like no
yeah like i like asians they just set me
up with an asian this ain't gonna work
what guy is that the asian
uh i forget it's never the asian guy
it's never the asian guy that's always
like that girl at the bottom with the
red hair
a handful what you mean farting burping
jumps when she gets excited she
uncontrollably jumps around
but and then she's super like judgy of
these other guys i'm like [ __ ]
you're lucky you're on a goddamn date
lucky got out there you've been going
hard though you've been gone the
gangster is the redhead right
the redhead dude he's probably the
gangster no they're going with the truth
the guy sitting down the bottom right
yeah yeah oh okay he looks
okay so [ __ ] funny you could just
tell him so funny
they go how you feeling so he talks like
this and he goes well you know what what
i'm and they go how you feeling what do
you think and he goes
i'm thinking about what words my wife's
gonna say at my funeral
and the dad's like damn no just go on
the first date don't wake up
don't worry about being married and
dying yeah yeah he's great so if
you ever see that [ __ ] uh uh the first
kiss show
it's a show i think it was on like bravo
is where these people like
meet each other for the first time and
they go kiss right away yeah did you
ever see that one with a
real awkward dude i don't think so you
guys know what i'm talking about
did you ever watch the first kiss did
you ever watch millionaire uh
matchmaker on there oh yeah but i i i
was on and off you like that
kiss i like this i like science on
sunshine that guy like this show this
one crain's first kiss you never seen
this
what is this oh what was the show called
love at first sight and that was office
on teals
this is cringey oh love it love that
first kiss dog really damn she ain't bad
everything so oh i do remember this
no but i'm kind of nervous watch oh he's
awkward
he looks like a hey hold up hey hold on
pause it
done
he looks like moe from the simpsons the
bartender
let me see this phone hold on
hold on oh just like mo from the
simpsons oh [ __ ] that that that took me
by surprise
that's exactly what he looks like bro
his walk up
yeah he's walking wall street you know
he was a baddie like he was a handsomer
they look identical
for the simpsons that's a good one hold
on wait go back to the walk up please
oh bro he thought he would
that boy got a boner
oh she's like she's like what the [ __ ]
and she's a dime piece yeah what's your
name
what's your name said can i kiss you
yeah
oh my god
and then he walks away are they supposed
to kiss on the lips yeah
i think so right what is happening
he just leaves the building at all
[Music]
i don't know i screwed up
i should've had the slumdog millionaire
like as long as oh bruh
let me see that uh the redhead girl in
that black guy kid yeah she kind of yeah
yeah i bet that's is that your homegirl
the freestyler no come on now don't do
it like that you know him
bro he started off i'm a hunter he said
pro mma fighter yeah you know him
yeah i like to clip the back leg from
under and i like to bite in the back of
the neck
what is it kind of aggressive yeah bro
oh first of all look at that
all i see is red hair boom instantly
ariel from the little mermaid i don't
know if i can get down with a cartoon
character damn
bro you look like one oh oh [ __ ]
oh oh [ __ ] oh oh
little tongue too did they make it does
the sound not mama you ain't gonna suck
his dick what
does the sound not bother you a little
bit but i'm more turned on
kiss somebody
[Music]
there's just that chemistry with the lip
sucking and the lip fighting and
[Music]
she was all about it i'm in for the
speed day
yeah i would like to get to know him a
little bit more really
right he got he got the makeup on his
face you see that oh
that's why i think yeah literally two
thousand let me tell you something i'm
gonna
[ __ ] this yeah
it's all over your face it's all over
you oh the lies the lot
but when i get off stage at the lab
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son